à la guerre en afghanistan au yémen
le choléra en haïti l'ebola au congo ces
médecins experts en santé publique ont
travaillé dans les pires conditions
aujourd'hui on leur demande d'aider à
sauver nos aînés dans des ch et celle
des as tant que médecin de profession en
tant que prestataire de soins donc je
vois qu'il y a un besoin d aide
je suis dans la communauté je peux aider
et j'y suis ce n'est pas l'afghanistan
ou le yémen dit il mais chaque pays a
ses propres problèmes dans la lutte
contre la copie de 19,1 des problèmes
dans les chs ldc qu'on a trop tardé à
isoler les malades de la queue vide
les équipes de la croix-rouge instaure
des protocoles de prévention des
infections à savoir comment se déplacer
dans une zone commence à sortir d'une
zone rouge est allé dans une zone verte
pour ne pas mélanger tous les patients
pour que les prestataires de soins de sa
part trois mélanges ils ont des limites
maison on s'assure qu'ils sont bien
indiqués
et que c'est aussi bien en ski et
qu'est-ce qu'on peut porter dans chaque
chambre
on a réclamé des bras pour éteindre
l'incendié mais on a négligé le coupe
feu ces mesures de prévention qui
peuvent empêcher le feu le virus de se
propager
c'est juste un certaines procédures qui
doivent être appliqués mais qui
n'étaient pas appliquées ce n'est pas
qu'ils ne connaissaient pas quoi faire
mais c'était juste on était dans une
situation d'urgence
on était dans une situation au tout le
monde on n'avait pas la tête à cela
ce que fait la croix rouge c'est l'abbé
c'est la base de tout plan de lutte
contre l'épidémie
plusieurs des médecins qui travaillent
dans les chs ld de l'ouest de l'île de
montréal ont réclamé l'instauration de
ces zones rouges
il y à plus d'un mois c'est clair qu'on
l'a demandé mais je le demandais en
criant dans mon entrée de garage ça sera
pareil c'est pas moi qui peut demander
la croix rouge dont moi qui peut
demander l'armée sauf que c'est ça qu'on
se questionner puis comment ça demandait
pourquoi on n'avait pas des brocs parce
qu on aurait aimé ça d avoir il ya un
mois
tu es de la réactivité est également
certain délai pour s'organiser mieux
s'organiser parce qu'on était plus dans
l'état d'urgence est en défaut la croix
rouge ne pouvait intervenir avant qu'on
en demande son aide qui est très
apprécié même le fait que les familles
entendent que la croix rouge et dans
notre ch est celle des bas ça fait ça
rassure et ça et ça rend les gens un peu
moins anxieux pour eux je crois que ça
les a soulagé un peu de nous voir
arriver
moi j'aimerais ça que la croix rouge
soit mise par tous qui crée des
champions qui souffre et mylène toute
cette information loc
pour l'instant les experts de la croix
rouge sont présents dans une dizaine de
ch et celle des dans l'ouest de montréal
mais les demandes augmentent de
nouvelles équipes sont en formation pour
aller en renfort dans d'autres centres
ici sophie langlois radio canada
montréal